sponsors of this segment they're back to
talk about peels one way they help our
skin stay glowy in this dry desert Katya
welcome back you're always giving us the
you know latest on skin care Trends and
this time we're talking about peels now
I'm hearing a lot about the TCA peel
right yeah yeah what is that explain it
and fall winter and spring times uh
perfect times to get chemical peels a
lot of the times when you look at the
person and they have enlarged pores
pigmentation dryness it makes them look
older by just having their skin look
dull right so chemical peel helps with
bringing that hydration plumpness to the
skin make your skin bouncy and glowy we
love that yeah we love that now what is
the process like we have our lovely
model here so it's very simple the
appointment takes only 15 to 20 minutes
that's it yes that's it and the best
part if you have a special event that
particular day you're gonna look your
best because the skin is going to look
glowy tight firm and you're going to
look your best your makeup is going to
go on very smooth so as you can see it's
very simple process I just wipe a little
pad with TCA peel on it
over the skin tighten up your lip like
this
and it can be done up to four layers it
can be done as strong as you want there
is no downtime unless you want down time
but you need to come for a consultation
to see us and we'll advise you what you
need to do for yourself of course of
course now this is obviously as you said
15 to 20 minutes you can do a day of
most people think chemical appeal they
need you know at least a few days for
the redness to go away but you're ready
yeah and we saw a couple before and
afters I think there was a man on screen
so this is for both women and men yes
who what makes the perfect candidate
because looking at it now before
everybody concerned about enlarged pores
pigmentation dryness and men and women
they want to look radiant fresh and have
the their skin bouncy everybody look I'm
looking at the the before forehead
versus the after forehead that is
incredible yeah 10 minutes I love what
it can do now what were you saying about
a man with a beard though how should
they take care of that so when you come
to an esthetician especially man and
they should not shave that's why on the
picture he has a little bit of hair
because especially for chemical peel
it's not recommended to shave before you
come and do chemical peel okay the night
before you can shave but not the day off
okay good to know you always have all
the advice right now is there a special
offer that you guys are doing for these
yes right now we we have BOGO on
chemical peels so you get one get second
one half off oh you should jump on that
and I'm gonna jump on that one we
recommend four to six treatments okay
it's great get ready for the holidays
you got your day up I'm here for it all
right yeah Pearl Skin studio a call at
702-525-5504 or just visit
pearlskinstudio.com again that special
offer book a TCA peel by PCA skin
mentioned Las Vegas now and receive 50
off your second TCA peel appointment
your appointment includes a seven day
supply of post-procedure skin care
products and that is excellent Kendall
send over to you hey real quick just
make sure our model is okay yeah yeah
we've seen zero movement over there I
just want to make sure there goes a
smile okay